Latin downs used case endings to mark the nouns function in a sentence.
Take the name Bruce as a subject.
It's in the nominative case.
Brutus became brutal as an object.
It's a neat accusative case.
The romance languages ditch this case system over the centuries,
but the few lingering remnants are worth our attention.
The basic form of a now comes from the accusative case.
We saw that last time,
so nominative Moodle's isn't the source of Italian Moodle,
French movie,
Romance meal,
etc. Those all come from the accusative Moodle,
which became vulgar Latin Moodle.
That's the general historical trend,
but there are exceptions.
Old French held onto the nominative for quite awhile.
Take the Latin down.
Lupus,
which meant wolf and the accused of form of it was Lupul,
old French distinguished,
a nominative bloops from an accusative loop.
Still the push to simplify was very strong and even modern French today just has
Lou.
The difference between nominative and accusative matters in the plural,
not in any single romance language,
but across the family.
Eastern romance languages take their plural forms from the Latin nominative.
So vulgar Latin Lupa with the nominative plural,
loopy,
gives us Italian blue boy and
the western romance languages hold onto the accusative plural instead.
So Lupu with the accusative plural do post gives us Sardinian,
Lupus and Lupus Romansh roof and loose for wolf and wolf.
What about the other Latin cases besides nominative and accusative?
For the most part,
they died out Romanian languages including standard Romanian [inaudible],
Romanian and related languages have endings.
Combining the genitive and dated cases,
what are those?
The genitive is like a possessive as in the wolf's bone and the date of
indicates a recipient to the wolf.
Romanian Casa has a genitive data form Caci,
but I see these Romanian genitive date of nouns with the definite article
articles that didn't even exist in classical Latin lupus.
Men Wolf,
a wolf or the wolf depending on context.
Vulgar Latin speakers innovated articles,
specifically the word Elu accusative case,
masculine gender for it.
That came to mean the with masculine nouns just as Ella did with feminine nouns.
Eloper Italian,
he Lupa to French Lulu,
Katelyn,
a yacht or a la Casa,
which gave us words like Italian,
Black Aza,
Galician.
Then Portuguese whittled the definite articles down to just Ooh and ahh.
As you see,
it's important to know the gender of your nouns.
The gender of the article matches the announced gender
Sardinian and belly Arik.
Katelyn views IEPs,
so the same word we find an ipso facto,
so it's [inaudible],
so Lupo and his Israel,
we find the feminine was east side,
so Sardinian and Katelyn side
in Romanian.
Definite articles attached to the end of a noun.
Lube oil.
Lou Not Isla.
Lupo explains Romanian loophole and Casa Eli Becomes Casa.
The plurals of these definite articles mimic the announced.
They sit in here by now.
You know that Lupo has the plural loopy in the east,
but lupus in the west and Casa has the plural Casa in the east,
but Casa us in the west.
You probably even remember why it's no surprise then that you Lupo has the
plural elution Lupus in the west Los Lobos.
They Lou is loose,
which low Bush or that illy loopy remains in the east.
He loopy in Italian and loopy in Romanian
languages.
Unanimously used the word one for the indefinite article.
We're not Casa.
The plural son is dealt with in various ways.
Many languages allow the bear.
Now
Iberian languages like Spanish may use the plural of one to mean son who knows
logos which low Bush French and Occitan use the Latin word day,
which means some of,
or some
they do.
Romanians can use [inaudible] as in [inaudible].
Romance languages are often skiddish about bear nouns,
especially as subjects we see Sardinian sort of Lupus or Italian,
he loopy,
we're English has just wolf's.
It's also true of bear singulars expect vulgar Latin Elijah [inaudible],
Italian luxurious Dexia,
French luxury steeze oh meaning v Justice instead of the non for justice by
itself.
That French and oxygen article with Dei is an instance of a partitive article.
You'll also find it in Italian Juva.
They'll vino means someway louver Iovino mean wine in general.
It's an innovation you won't find in languages along the periphery.
Spanish,
Portuguese or Romanian for instance.
Last back to those Romanian articles and that curious genitive date of case
Romanian nouns tack an article to their back as an ending.
We've already seen that with Lupul and loopy that ending changes in the genitive
data
loop loop,
loop loop.
Lulu,
if you've been following along and maybe taking notes over the last two videos,
you'll have some understanding of how nouns work in the romance languages.
We're going to build on that,
but next time we focus our attention on verbs.